bonsoir martin veyron bonsoir margoline
bonsoir quand j'ai lu vos vies j'ai vu
que vous étiez tous les trois pieds
noirs non oui les gars on s'égare 60
pieds noirs qui est auvergnate où l'on
fasse si on veut et pourquoi vous avez
perdu l'accent parce que oui tu vois
qu'il a fait nous un petit plan comme ça
là bas et on n'est pas typé du tout pour
donner un peu dur à toi un peu quand
même un petit peu mieux on a donné il ya
que toi merci à commence à se gâter les
miracles avec les superstars dans l'axé
bin il ya des limites ça fout la
trouille
alors comment ça se passe avec lescure
innocent sur certains trucs c'est moi on
m'a dit là l'histoire du chien l'a quand
même oui alors c'est quoi ces témoins
avaient raconté sans parenté
on avait envie pour démarrer les
émissions de bahts faire un petit clin
d'oeil si j'ose dire aux otages oui bon
on était allé tourner un jour dans une
spa et on avait vu des chiens comme ça a
senti des vacances tous derrière des
barreaux et tout et on s'est dit oh les
pauvres sont emprisonnés eux aussi voilà
j'en avais envie de faire de 200
cinquième jour de détention que sur le
jeu et on était vachement fier de cette
idée et un soir au restaurant soit avec
lescure effectivement on lui en parle
au départ ils étaient un peu
enthousiasmant ouais c'est vrai que
c'est drôle puis le lendemain après une
nuit de réflexion nous a convoqués en a
parlé tous ensemble ça peut être une
censure nous avez vous pensez vraiment
que c'est drôle au club pour la première
c'était la première
un moyen aussi pour faire des trucs pas
mal à ce qu'on vient de voir sa part le
monde parle de ça les discussions
panique sensuelle et basf alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé là c'est la société
basf qui est beau ryan johnson flammes
je pense que c'est les initiales j'ai
connu bien des regards très jolie fille
qui eux ont vu les photos dans le monde
je crois c'est l heure actuelle aussi
donc il y avait la tronche de kurt
valdingue le truc c'était donc il
pleurait sur des chants nazis cbs est ce
l'émotion intacte
ils ont juste cette image est là la pub
de savourer et donc ils ont bloqué je
vois kw avec un référé ces prêts pour
babel la guerre il était sais pas si on
veut pas dire avoir une autre procession
d'agde
ah oui d'accord mais ils sont quand même
assez mouillé dans les larmes
ils ont déjà beaucoup de lui alors le 7
d'or il vous augmentez chez canal+ parce
qu'ils sont plein de thunes chez canal+
nous ont tenté avant cela d'autres
avançaient d'échangés tués
il s'agit prince se renseigner et vous
avez des propositions de bouygues
comptes annuels
là et alors ça c'est passé raconté comme
des propositions nous a demandé si on
voulait aller faire une chanson du to
break
on est bien canal quoi on a des
interlocuteurs valables dans les jambes
fayoter simplement je suis honnêtement
est-ce que ce qui passe à l'heure
actuelle sur notre chan sur canal ça
pourrait passer à une heure de grande
écoute si on a une qui s'est passé
45 c'est pas évident de changer ça
change plus d'eau dans le sens de la
roue de la fortune que dans le champ au
sens de tony glande il faut bien le dire
c'est pas de marseillais a même cru
remarquer jean marc marquez s'est pas
très drôle même et c'est bien bon alors
on va tous les prendre un par an là
puisque vous faites un journal télévisé
nullement gildas je vous demanderai pas
ce que vous en pensez parce que
j'imagine que c'est votre pâte gildas
mahé alors poivre d'arvor alors la nuit
avant un lieu c'est le pire
je l'avais personnes ouais je suis bien
à lui c'est le pire il fait d'abord
savoir pourquoi ses chances acsé
épidermique mais pourquoi et pda bouton
à bord oui lui alors qu'il est plein il
est pas plus mal car les mois chauds
niveau après mon sosie jeu j'aime bien
le nominer sabrina sérions govou est un
rigolo un petit plus que je sais même
pas qui c'est aujourd'hui on est gentil
anti oxydantes et ajouté un couplet cuba
da tu vas sûrement prise à dakar
guillaume durand m avec gem du portrait
bien on efface les quais sur l'a5 le
dimanche ça français tous sachent
combien ça c'est bien
pendant qu'un jean claude bourret et
bien il a un nom prédestiné mais bon
alors tu as bien mais ça va bien
ex-aequo avec jean pierre clermont
ex-aequo là j'ai pas pensé à jean paul
bruno masure j'aime bien alors avec
police ont donc tout ce que vous dites
que vous aimez bien c'est que vous
feriez bien le jt n avait que oui c'est
ça joseph poli sans faute d'accord henri
sannier jamais servi en plein champ sur
un point il s'agit ténébreux je suis là
parce qu'on n'a jamais vous j'ai jamais
vu en gîte et ouais vos concurrents
patrick sébastien j'aime bien moi je
trouve que c'est d'action la démo les
ajustements et ça je veux dire parce que
son émission il assure le maire non il
se décarcasse
non il se décarcasse ce mec faut pas
déconner faut regarder ce qui fait qu'en
vingt jeux gagnés sur des idées on aime
qu'on aime pas bon qu'on lui reproche un
peu c'est d'être un peu trop gentil avec
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il aime trop
tout le monde mais quand même ya tout le
temps des retrouvailles des pieds noirs
qui laisse pas une femme moi fils de
pionnier
ça c'est alors maintenant collaro on
aime bien ça parce que vous êtes dans la
salle ty à d'autres programmes de la
secte pourquoi alors vous payez sur le
site sur la session d'assises alors on
n'est pas au programme de nuit le roux
cas ce que je peux dire j'aime pas dans
un bon héros castries s'est pas cassé
moins bien que les nullités
il s'est passé ça nous fait pas rire non
mais ça fait pas vendre entre les
générations enfin les inconnues sont
comme au centquatre et bien sûr sa part
jamais vu sur scène alors les imitateurs
manon andré lamy il est muté lurons
limites que les morts a annoncé à mais
qu'il pourrait se mettre
mais qui est capable d'imiter coluche
tout ça il se met sur un drap avec
quatre bougies autour sur un drap noir
et sera parfait alors eric blanc qui
sait ça c'est le marché pour moi j'ai
jamais à bord très honnêtement non il
est formé à la télévision ça aide pas
souvent quand on fait du skate quand on
prend comme ça une équipe où il est bien
difficile mais en vidéo
il fait bien mitterrand et bien giscard
il fait bien bel et bien c'est qu'on
arrive à oublier dans ses imitations que
des noirs ouais ouais ouais il est noir
c'est le noir qui me les blancs et de
ses journaux beaucoup de choses
alors est ce que vous connaissez martin
veyron intérêt à dire oui
d'accord l'amour propre ne le reste
jamais très longtemps mais un martin
martin parle nous de ton livre mon
dernier livre tant dernier livre bien il
sort quelques années après le labour
proches ouais et après que ces gens qui
sont un petit peu énervé rue dans
l'amour propre et quand je mets ça donne
ça allait mal élevés ils se marieront
jamais faite pour les hommes qui
prévient pour élever l'enfant et ça dit
quoi par exemple du mois un truc le plus
drôle du livre boom a rendu tout d'abord
c'est très sérieux c'est fait pour
élever les chiens viasat a eu le plaisir
maintenant tu paies et autant que ce
soit bien fait combien de chiens mais
moi je dis oui il ya eu une petite fille
en disgrâce et chef il met en exergue
alors c'est une fois ce qui dit les
enfants c'est comme l'épée on ne
supporte que nessia c'est bien c'est pas
mal général et sai d'elisabeth ch c'est
qu'ils abattent sherer c'est pas une
copine heideger david ferrer c'est une
c'est une philosophe c'est ma tante en
plus avant mais mais la raison en marque
de l'insee qui mattotti dessus et je le
connais pas à matadi celle ci ne soit
révélée ouais il se trouve que à mal
ouais qu'est ce qu'il raconte moi c'est
beau qu'est ce qu'il raconte en bd ouais
on met des histoires assez assez
personnelle assez monde et demande
intérieure philosophique c'est un peu à
part c'est il ya trois ans il ya le
directeur artistique de banny tic
magazine italien au bugue qui s'est dit
tiens on fait toujours faire la mode
pour les photographes pourquoi on
demanderait pas à des dessinateurs de bd
parce que mon la bd donc et bien et il a
donc demandé m atelier à l'autre de gens
de d'illustrer le travail des designers
et ça a très bien marché
les stylistes était content pour ce
qu'on vendait bien leurs modèles la
revue du coup à bien marcher
et le résultat c'est ce livre là assez
ça j'ai des trucs assez mattotti pour
magnifier où l accord c'est tout ce
qu'il a fait pour illustrer la mala très
bien vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
les enfants n'ont établi sur la scène
qu'elle raconte alors sur la saq on m'a
jamais rien interdit justement je les
extraordinaires
d'ailleurs on me laisse faire tout ce
que je veux et si c'est pas terrible ce
n'est pas de leur faute à des trucs un
peu salée ça arrive ça arrive donc ya
pas deux par exemple est-ce que la fille
du générique elle plonge tout à chaque
émission lui associé à kevin se met
d'accord alors là ça ben ali
ricol gurls vous n en bricolage
voilà parce que vous êtes nuls en
bricolage - et vous avez décidé de faire
cadeau à un cadeau pas vraiment cadeau
ça vaut combien je ne sais pas bricoler
et j'aime les belles filles c'est un
concept que j'ai réunis en une seule
cassette
vous avez fait casting comment j'imagine
c'est pas en strips soutien-gorge petite
culotte ce qu'on n'a pas des forcément
des idées qui passent pas les bouger la
perceuse un peu le tout petit peu tu
sais je vais sur mes cinquante donc ça
commence à être moi
des numéros absurde et charme incroyable
sûr que non mais en fait non mais c'est
vrai que c'était c'est difficile de dire
voilà vous avez donc décollé du papier
peint ça dégage de la vapeur il fait
très chaud vous déshabiller pour être
plus à l'aise les hits quand même mettre
les filles à l'aise si oui oui mais mais
je leur ai dit que c'était extrêmement
extrêmement c'était plus que et qu'aucun
plus que puisque même sexy il a quand
même fait le crépi à la fin est la
sienne un peu hard
est ce qu'après vous allez faire d'autre
qu'à celle avant de rejoindre l'équipe
schendel qui sont d'aider les
magnifiques chippendales qui vont donner
des recettes de cuisine le casting par
est cordialement invitée renda parce que
le casting sera effectivement fait part
des copines pour avoir un peu leurs
canons masculin quoi voilà en fait au
départ on devait sortir et dort même
temps puis on est passé de sous à huy
canal + vidéo n'a pas assez de ça non
mais là personne n'en voulait moi j'ai
fait tout seul et puis après je les
proposer à canal que dit oui mais ah oui
c'est une idée vraiment à vous au départ
c'était pour perdre de l'argent un petit
peu d'ambition artistique moi c'est une
ambition artistique une vrai qu'à cette
pratique bien alors votre premier film
c'était là on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
cité de la peur après le gazon maudit
qui a été quand même le film qui vous a
fait connaître en tant qu' en tant
qu'acteur c'est vrai que celui de
l'eczéma sous les bras tellement vous
aviez le trac mais c'est exact c'est
très glamour parce que j'avais une image
non non
oui je vous retrouver dans l'intimité
avec alain chabat vous demandez lui de
lever les bras sylla de l'eczéma dessous
les bras ces quelques heures il ya un
tournage en prévision voilà merci
thierry à sebala c'était à l'achat mais
le pire est à venir
le prix à payer le cousin métier
extraordinaire commun vraiment vous a
découvert comme acteur non parce qu'au
début on vous prenez un peu pour un
problème futur et vérité je suis un
branleur
mais non c'est une imposture dans super
bon comédien oui vous pensez toujours
que ça va s'arrêter que les gens vont
vous diront s'apercevoir un jour que
c'est nous messieurs j'ai beaucoup de
grands acteurs qui pensent ça c'est pour
ça que je vous dis ça il pense toujours
qu'un jour là là le carrosse va
redevenir une citrouille vous pensez ça
bien sûr non mais oui c c on pense que
ce serait très grave on voulait ça va ya
des trucs plus grave mais dans le
présent j'étais très bien merci était
bien dirigée par monsieur corneau sur
toi alors lui didier vous avez réalisés
dont là je vous remettre votre petit
[Musique]
alors la personne je crois que vous
allez faire votre premier film c'est
diane kurys et après celui des ennuis
avec elle au sujet de didier germain
qu'on en parle parce qu'on a vu de tout
temps des petits bouts dans les journaux
où elle vous accuser de plagiat en
disant c'est une idée didier que j'ai
raconté un soir dans un dîner à alain
chabat et puis je marquais les 10 ha
ouais non je prédictions ou alors parce
que comme ça ce sera clair ouais
non c'est un je crois qui a développé
aux états unis un sujet sur un petit
garçon qui transformait son frère en
chien un truc comme ça et après moi je
vais raconter mon truc gémit tiens je me
prépare ça et c'est tout ça ensuite me
revient cette histoire qu'elle avait
déjà développé en fait avant avant que
je lui parle de ça mais je ne le savais
pas et on me dit tiens et développe elle
développe un film avec un mec qui se
transforme en chien ou j'sais pas quoi
donc forcément je me prends les nerfs
parce que j'avais raconté le truc donc
je l'appelle et les insultes enfin je
l'insultais les idées n'appartiennent
pas à ce qu'ils ont entendu les
appartiennent ils ont trouvé samedi mais
non mais non mais non finalement 1 est
effectivement enfin elle avait raison vu
qu'elle l'avait vraiment développer
alors voilà quelqu'un moi je le savais
pas donc après comme on s'est embrouillé
tous les deux le truc a donné ce à quoi
l'autre cas donné il a plagié mon film
américain avec un barman déjà pour
diabolo menthe
elle est coutumière du fait en fait on
nageait n'y a jamais eu de procès on
sait juste expliquer tous les deux il
n'y a ni procès ni plagiat mais est ce
que c'est pour ça qu'il ya pas eu un
didier parce qu'à un moment où vous
deviez faire la version américaine le
didier est ce que c'est pour ça qu'il ya
eu la version américaine
non non non non la version américaine
est dit est toujours acheté par miramax
qui est une société de production un
week-end avec les frères weinstein et on
a travaillé dessus presque un an et demi
mais au bout d'un moment j'étais obligé
de leur dire j'avais j'avais une vie
quoi et que je pouvais pas attendre
assis sur une caisse que le truc se
fasse pas donc je suis rentré à ma
maison quand vous étiez partis vivre là
bas je faisais des allers retours j'ai
fait des allers-retours est beaucoup
entre
paris et new york ce qui est agréable
c'est est payé par la production était
ravie je vais manger des hot dogs et
grossier et tout ça et mon cul est
devenue une véritable usine à merde là
bas c'est monstrueux quand on fait ce
qu'on fit mais sinon c'était donc voilà
donc ils semblent ils le font avec un
autre metteur en scène qui s'appelle
stephen schwartz qui avait fait chou
thing fish qui mettait en scène anglais
très bien donc maintenant bon courage à
lui parce qu'il sait pas des rapides
quoi ouais ouais alors ça quand même un
mal pour un bien parce que ça vous
permet de faire la suite d'astérix
c'est fait ça non non c'est j'ai
commencé à écrire donc voilà qu'il fait
ça voilà ouais ça risque d'être moins
franchouillard que diddy série z plus
marrant non
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas j'ai envie
de faire ma version à moins d'être
associé non non j'ai pas d'instructions
g je fais ce régime il y en aurait créé
avec call casting c'est pourquoi non
pour savoir si clavier valeur reprendre
le rôle moi je trouve qu'il n'est pas
crédible dans le rôle mais non pas
savoir si tu changes ça non je ne change
pas clavier je ne change pas de part
dieu c'est astérix et cléopâtre il ya
ces adjani ou bouquets alors cessé c'est
très gênant parce que sais je sais pas
qui s'est vu que effectivement ses
sorties je choisirai effectivement qu'on
était dit un peu rapidement
donc j'ai jamais rencontré adjani je
suis j'aime beaucoup adjani comme
comédienne mais non j'en suis à
l'écriture et je ne sais même pas qui va
faire faire payer ce bonus est pas une
bonne idée
il ya jamel c'est sûr ça qui fait
l'architecte de colobane on n'y a rien
de gharyane sur un an
rien de sûr pour nous enfumer les
pétards en écrivant le script c'est le
meilleur moment c'est le meilleur moment
exactement
ouais quand on monte les marches ouais
elle connait sacha guitry fait de
meilleur moment dans l'amour c'est
exactement ce parallèle à l'écriture
ouais je cultive un joli nez linda aussi
il est gentil
c'est pour ces la truffe du chien
alors on va faire un tabac une interview
à lambertz est ce que c'est une
interview l'envers oui c'est donner les
réponses et
bien j'avais un canada suit l'émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà comme ça surtout parce qu'elle
sait très bien alors je vous donne les
réponses comme vous l'avez dit fait
clairement et puis vous me donnez les
questions alors la réponse les tendances
et fabrice luchini qui est le meilleur
acteur français parce que vient en même
temps avec lui philippe sollers
[ __ ] alors je n'ai jamais lu un livre
de comment il s'appelle déjà
je suis totalement inculte mais aussi
parce qu'elle célèbre écrivain français
a une coupe de mr nô si cela marche bien
donc je donne la réponse
laurent baffie moi je dirais que c'est
un type formidable
déjà je parle à des six routes et
humains de la personne ouais puis après
tu peut broder là dessus qu'il ya ce
mélange de grâce d'humour de talent de
sex-appeal
je sais pas linda hardy qui mériterait
d'avoir des plus grosses
mettez votre main ici ce que je sais ce
que vous non par la suite un travail de
la proche la vie la série je suis marié
j'ai des enfants bien dans un peu de
tenue qui a la main droite qui part un
peu en couille
bravo tu sais très bien continuer c'est
très bien guy bedos qui ne manque pas de
toupet bien qu'on nous applaudit on
rallume la lumière
je viens de nous arrêter
ils vont nous arrêter à merci bonjour
demande de vous arrêter doit aussi
arrête toi maintenant ça c'est filmé en
haut je suis là alors le tueur donc
alain chabat gérard darmon
vous êtes ici pour la sortie du film
astérix mais en fait vous avez pas
besoin de promotion ce film faire un
carton intégral c'est ça vous avez eu
les chiffres et où tous témoins tout est
bon mais salue donc céder
comment je suis rassuré d'impôt est
facile franchement y'a pas de quoi son
soutien mais quelle récompense mais sait
on s'attendait pas à autant de césar
mais pour les comédies en général y en a
pas il y en a douze césars ou césar
douze césars huawei dont 11 pour
d'armonk est quand même incroyable dans
le fait qu est ce qui explique ma venue
ici et on croit alors comment ça va bien
alors
astérix et obélix mission cléopâtre donc
c'est votre nouveau film avec vous
gérard darmon et une pléiade de vedettes
alors je vais faire le pitch qui est
vachement simple en plus à faire
cléopâtre veut un palais en trois mois
vous vous êtes son architecte mais elle
veut pas de vous parce que vous trouvez
un peu dépassée quand même un peu démodé
du clasico oui elle choisit jamel qui
évidemment pour réussir à faire ce
palais pour césar qu'est vous en trois
mois fait appel à astérix et obélix et
surtout à leur potion magique voilà
alors casting de rêve il ya monica
bellucci djamel alain chabat gérard
darmon edouard baer dieudonné claude
rich
chantal lauby les robin jean benguigui
isabelle nanty dominique besnehard
noémie lenoir magnifique magnifique noir
comment qui ne s'use pas
j'ai suivi ce qu'est ce qui peut nuire
dans le film astérix est très amoureux
de noémie lenoir et chaque fois qu'il la
voit on entend ou berthod totsi voilà
alors emma de caunes c'est énorme
claude berri est aussi est aussi gérard
depardieu et christian clavier
les huit mois c'est pour ça qu'ils font
pas de promo la clavier et depardieu
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment d'avoir
été un petit peu mieux si ça va mal non
que la vie a fait un peu de promo gérard
aussi il a fait de la promo il nous a
fait une bonne petite journée
d'interviews avant autre jour tout va
bien tout va bien ou bien alors il n'ya
pas joey starr qui devait s'appeler
nique la police pourquoi parce que j'ai
jugé que j'ai coupé la scène l'écriture
quoi ma d'accord voilà y'a pas farrugia
non parce que farrugia devait jouer
cléopâtre ça c'est un truc qui était
tu as et avait vu les essais moi j'adore
monica bien sûr magnifique tv j'ai vu
les essais c'était autre chose c'était
enfin ça alors tout le monde s'y est mis
votre pote bakri a écrit quelques
blagues
besson par exemple que passer par un
philanthrope besson mais il est venu
pendant une journée il est venu faire ça
l'amusé où il devait tourner la caméra
et de fer caméra 3 sur le tournoi là un
jour difficile en plus ouais y avait
2000 figurants il y avait du monde il ya
les potes il ya la famille à carole
chabat il ya max chabat il ya momo de
bouge le frère de jamel qui vend des
sphinx miniature tout à fait voilà qui a
été qui a été catégorique était la régie
dans ce que j'aime bien quand même c'est
d'arriver à faire un film de potes à 50
millions d'euros quoi c'est vrai c'est
sympathique jeudi pour les gens c'est
350 millions de francs quand même ouais
ouais ouais et le prix de la place reste
le même le premier avait fait 9 millions
d'entrées
nous allons faire 15 à peu près non je
sais pas c'était quoi les chiffres il y
en a sur paris à paris premier jour
jours ce qui est génial c'est que c'est
un film de potes à 50 millions d'euros
et puis que c'est aussi un arabe questar
dans un film de gaulois quoi entouré de
quelques jouets sont entourés de
quelques jeux
bien des juifs il ya des arabes des
martiens et des maltais ya des marocains
et des il ya plein de [ __ ] dans le
film c'est comment on fait les enfants
du sétois seconde j'ai préféré un truc
oui
laurent tu vois le verre n'entend pas
l'embellie vous a proposé claude berri
vous a proposé vous ai fait un peu votre
chauffeur du bus mais comment vous savez
tout ça parce que je peux vous le faire
à chaque question
c'est ce que je ferai à chaque fois
merci les enfants de vous inviter
voilà vous avez fait un peu la chochotte
non c'est vrai pourquoi ce que j'étais
en train d'écrire un scénario que je
pense est bon qu'ils étaient pas bon et
donc j'ai dit non je suis en train
d'écrire un truc donc non j'ai pas envie
de faire astérix créé plus en plus la
bande dessinée quand même votre truc
j'adore je suis de suite parce que moi
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est
que la première ambition d'alain chabat
quand il vivait à massy après que ça les
amis aient quitté oran alain chabat le
petit pied noir exilés rêver des toiles
disney oui oui alors c'est vrai nom vous
êtes branché bande dessinée depuis
toujours sûr je voulais être successeur
de walt disney quand j'étais petit
j'avais même mis ça sur profession plus
tard je crois au cm1 ok c'est pas ça
peut arriver parce que maintenant on vu
le succès que vous avez vous connaissez
400 berck tous ces mecs là je tutoie les
plus grands
ça peut arriver alors l'avantagé quand
même du premier astérix c'est comme ça a
posé un peu les personnages ça a permis
quand même de voir qu'on pouvait faire
astérix au cinéma vous arriver là dessus
après je dirais que c'est un petit peu
plus facile de déconner au deuxième
absolument tout ça pour faire plaisir
avec l'audi quand même non mais c'est
vrai que et même à je veux dire
depardieu clavier accepter des rôles
comme ça c'est quand même d'aider rôle
c'est très très improbable jouer un
petit goût doit comme ça avec un drone
et les moustaches etc
alors bon pourquoi ça nous plaît parce
que là il ya des influences qui nous
plaisent de toute façon ce mel brooks
comme influences il ya mike myers et les
monty python il ya zac ce qu'ils ont
fait ils y at il un pilote dans l'avion
bien les nuls ya des 1000 bien sûr il ya
jean yanne deux heures moins le quart
avant jésus christ et sylves et 2000 il
ya des scènes laisser ça là des scènes
succès
genre
à lomé
le vieux
c'est tout l'esprit du film c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas vu le film qui était alors il
ya des gags somptueux que je vais pas
raconter bien entendu c'est pourri il ya
pas mal de références il ya des passages
en dessin animé qui sont très très bien
fait j'espère que c'est quand même une
histoire on regarde quand même un film
d'astérix et obélix
oui j'adore quand même pas être par
dessus tout goscinny uderzo
non mais attendez meilleur face à mais
c'est vrai que les enfants verront un
film d'astérix et obélix et les vieux
enfants comme nous verrons qui est en
mon pouvoir pour ma part j'ai vu une
belle merde il sorti avant la fin voilà
il dit alors tout ça a commencé alain
chabat le jour où vous avez réalisé
qu'on a le droit finalement et c'est
vous qui le dites de finir une bagarre
dans le studio du film qui tourne à côté
un jour aperçu de sa non mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des trucs qui m'ont mis des
gifles comme le shérif est en prison
l'effectif de mel brooks de ben ouais
effectivement une bagarre de saloon qui
finit dans un autre studio cinéma il ya
des gros pollueurs du qui danse avec
avec des primes depuis 20 semaines le
tournage quand même hein vous êtes un
vrai patron il paraît que vous êtes
dirigé ça avec beaucoup de bons toujours
très perfectionniste évidemment et
beaucoup de calme ouais je suis plus ça
dépend des jours mais en général je suis
super super nerveux mais c'est la drogue
beaucoup qu'il faut ça emballant drogue
je suis là je le raconte quand même il
reste presque plus de potion magique
dans la petite fiole darmon qui fait ça
si l'écran est il fait
suivant la revente est ce normal
les gens racontent pas d'autres y en a
plein alors oui non vous êtes tellement
calme et yuki vous appelez sur un
tournage casse-cou x tranquille x ah bon
vous savez pas si vous n'avez pas une
invention south est assez vrai ou c'est
fou là c'est vrai vous saviez pas n'en
fait pas non chaque casque ou x
tranquille x ouais mais ça me va bien et
jamel je vous l ai fait tous les soirs
le nom faisait pas des fêtes tous les
soirs c'est une légende il faisait des
fêtes le en général le vendredi soir ou
le samedi soir 1 samedi soir au maroc
puisse contourner six jours sur sept
le samedi soir il y avait de toute façon
une teuf qui était organisé par où les
où les comédiens ou un comédien ou les
costumes ou les décors etc et aussi
applaudi de toronto le mardi 13 mercredi
le jeudi à tous les jeudis et puis après
le week-end du samedi dimanche normal
moi j'ai raté tout ça et moi j'allais à
celle du samedi soir bah oui vous êtes
bien marré a complètement perturbé ça a
duré longtemps en plus sa durée
22 semaines bon bien alors sorti dans
950 salle ces normes
oui c'est une grosse sortie c'est sûr
c'est une très très grosse sortie déjà
vendu aux usa par miramax voilà pyramix
miramas et dans le reste du monde
bientôt non le reste du monde à acheter
comme le premier à marcher vraiment
partout en europe
the world mais il vous le dira jamais
mais c'est vrai qu'il a abattu un
travail colossal au c'est un travail
colossal de films il a il a bossé comme
incroyable façon il est il est né pour
sa ville a bossé comme un couac en
bonnes réponses un viable alors joue
avec la pression toujours de faire un
court métrage quoi ça qui était
incroyable alors vous en faite un jour
vous dînez avec votre ami vincent lindon
oui et vincent vous dit tu sais que
chabat prépare son astérix
vous n'aviez pas et je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais qui fument j'étais c'était
dans ma bulle
entre autres j'étais dans ma bulle ou et
j'étais un peu j'étais un peu office
depot que j'ai ça se passait bon ça
n'allait pas trop bien ça arrive dans la
vie pourquoi te féliciter quoi alors je
vais t'expliquer gerra exactement où
j'en étais sûr ça suffit pas toujours
non mais c'est un sentimental d'arbres
alors vous appeler alain chabab lui dit
alors non je dis pas alors je viens à
l'instant je veux prendre un petit café
avec toi et me dit ok
une sale période mais voilà je lui dit
j'aimerais bien faire partie de cette
aventure
1 je sais pas quoi et et très
franchement je dis toujours entre la fin
de ma question et sa réponse il s'est
passé quoi j'ai pas une seconde à quoi
même pas il a dit je ne sais pas dans
quoi
ouais je suis d'accord voilà il
apparaîtrait de l'appeler parce
qu'autant je n'ai pas aimé le film est
autant j'ai trouvé gérard formule 1 je
trouve que vraiment il crève l'écran et
il appréhender ce rôle de méchant de
façon fantastique et je trouve qu'il
réhabilite un peu le fil mais cette
débauche d'effets spéciaux est ce
dégueulis de fréquences
ceci étant je suis étant c'est vrai que
vos personnages ordinaires dans le sud
c'est beaucoup du bourg de vous déguiser
comme ça et surtout vous avez inventé un
personnage qui est le premier reptile
humain et ça c'est dit souvent ça s'est
décidé la veille du tournage oui c'est
comme ça c'est dans l'est dans les dents
dans les affres de l'acteur qui va qui
veut pas les infos de l'acteur c'est la
richesse du maroc dit la vérité aussi
mais ça veut dire ça on avec
ensuite parce que vous avez inventé ce
truc d'une espèce de rire sifflement
comme ça oui je me suis dit tiens
comment comment qu est ce qui risque
perçu ce 6e mais qu'il est bon c'est un
méchant ça c'est un méchant reculé que
qui skie qu'est ce qu'il doit bien rire
un bon donc voilà j'ai obligé pas payer
ça fait moins bien
vous avez souffert parce que ce tournage
en plein désert 45° des frais 55 degrés
et là vous dites les bijoux chauffer on
a eu des fous rires dit de chaleur on
est des fous rires de chaleur
oui parce qu'on avait enlevé la tête
pleine d'eau quoi c'est plus de cerveau
il devait faire à peu près 50 55 c'est
fou 14h dans dr à ouarzazate en plein
mois de jeûne c'est quoi il faisait 45
sous la tente de césarée mais de la fiom
toute la jambe à la une équipe de cinéma
les projos les flambeaux c'était
infernal et en plus les bouger les
bougies et les bijoux
voilà monsieur tous ces mois chabal
acteurs qui se droguent série conducteur
girl aurait serré pendant lés prises je
me brûler les doigts ont simplement
luisant au mont césar et la somme on
peut déjà il rien venu déjà du bruit et
or après quand vous êtes rentré en
europe
en studio on vous a obligé à jouer la
scène avec jamel où vous marchez sur les
murs enfin comme dans les films de hong
kong
voilà sur les colonnes et tout ça avec
des pans du pendu a parfois la manche en
hiver pas de chauffage demande lui a dit
m et puis cinoche 1-1 coûte à chaud
c'est ça qui est beau en même temps
c'est d'abord le travail la maj
l'industrie du rêve
le meilleur souvenir du tournage alain
c'est quoi ça parle de cacher là on
parle
non c'est le franchement c'est le
tournis super mauvais en anecdotes mais
c'est vrai que c'est le tournage c'est
le l'humeur générale le meilleur
souvenir c'est le tournage le plus
mauvais souvenir le plus mauvais
souvenir c'est le c'est pas des mauvais
souvenirs mais c'est vrai que j'ai
dirigé une ou deux scènes des chiottes
parce que je m'étais pris une vraie
bonne tourista et donc je suis auto qui
dans les chiottes assis sur les
moniteurs de contrôle même pas le
moniteur de contrôle il ya des
assistants qui fait ces prêts tu veux
vérifier je fais non c'est bon ça l'est
chabat et gendarmes ont ce film va être
un énorme succès vous ne m'en voudrez
pas de vous faire une interview et nous
porte et de catastrophes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alain chabat
le jour même de votre mariage vous avez
le coup de foudre pour une autre et
c'est réciproque
vous faites quoi
compliqué c'est compliqué je suis très
lâche je dis oui mon amour
si je fais
à
on n'est pas à l'abri de la catastrophe
donc le jour du mariage coup de foudre
pour une autre c'est réciproque vous
fait foi
je sais pas ça vous est déjà arrivé
peut-être en fait jour merci de m'aider
je sais pas je pense que moi j'aime bien
les choses quand elles arrivent alors
je sais pas si c'est une chose qui peut
être faite immédiatement je le fais
jouer après c'est vraiment un coup de
foudre au placard oui ne change pas
alors vous êtes
en vacances avec toute votre famille
vous retrouvez seul avec votre belle
mère qui vous fait des avances
c'est d'après midi tout le monde est à
la mer vous êtes seul avec mamie givet
eh oui
un mois ce sans aucune hésitation j'y
vais au cinéma l'oeil
c'est bon à savoir oui oui votre femme
quels atouts les chiffres du loto mais
vous avez oublié de valider le bulletin
à lui dit que ça comment
moi je dis gagner du temps ouais c'est
ça qui est important ça c'est de gagner
du temps et vienne est du pays où vous
faites comment faire je lui dit donne
moi le
le billet que toi que tu a coché oui
mais non c'est toi qui n'as rien tu
comprends pourquoi on s'est jamais
mariée c'est tout alors vous aller
draguer une nana super vraiment super ça
c'est vrai je suis témoin vous la
ramenez chez vous vous découvrez que
c'est un travesti vous réagissez comme
on ne savait pas arrivé mais
ok je dis oui ça m'est arrivé
bully ray
pas de problème il faut aimer les femmes
avec des grands hôpitaux rythme je suis
dopé m
oui
est ce que votre père regarde l'émission
la voix quand je dis des gros mots et
quand je me moque des faibles
voilà la raison il a raison à mort
là-dessus la raison d'un gros clitoris
est pas un gros bof c'est donc ça passe
voilà c'est même un nom égyptiens gros
qui tories donc ça reste dans la mission
cléopâtre c'est la promo voilà il a fait
de la promo papa ouais mon père pour moi
il est juge toujours à l'école comment
ça va bien claude berri il est content
de ton travail
pierre lescure il trouve que tu
travailles bien mais c'est mon fan
numéro 000 et quand même c'est lui que
j'ai vu à burger quiz directement avec
le père de fer rogers way avec le papa
de farouches alors attention interview
catastrophe contrôle de routine sur la
route pendant que les flics inspectent
le véhicule votre pote qui était assis à
côté de vous vous avoue qu'il transporte
1 kg de cocaïne dans son sac et vous
l'avez pas dit bien sûr n'est sûr fait
quoi
je me couvre mais après on partage
ça s'est pas passé comme ça dans la rue
je sais quoi ce que je fais tout d'un
coup il a fait un film derrière de quoi
c'est à dire quoi que j'ai pas compris
dans une bagnole
oui d'accord là je comprends le pote
avec qui vous êtes je suis aussi au
moment où les flics arrivent
j'ai un kg de coke dans le sac oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait faites quoi vous me
dites à tête est un gros con va essayer
de s'en sortir seul vol 1
on essaie de 2,2 passes et ce qu'on le
jette après voilà donc
on fait l'apologie ça c'est vraiment
pour la banane bien votre fils vous
annonce qu'il va se marier quatre ans
une mission était bon pour toujours
c'est tout l'esprit oui la jeune fille
s'appelle ben laden à munichois vasini
que la musique
pour sauver la population d'une ville
vous êtes bruce willis pour sauver la
population d'une ville bouge et faire
sauter un train yes et votre femme et
vos enfants sont à bord alors
fait quoi désolé pour les villes ça va
pas être possible la sûreté qui désole
alain chabat interview catastrophe
vous partez en vacances à l'île maurice
et rigolote salaire est bien
c'est lui
ainsi alain chabat et jean-paul room
[Musique]
ça va
jean paloma dames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
alors merci dans
c'est très gentil
merci beaucoup à ça vous
et et et et l'eau et leurs mamans
ouais
[Applaudissements]
votre ménage bonsoir si vous me la remet
bien sûr c'est jabba fiers de nous de
faire des petits quand même c'est
formidable ce qui leur arrive à la elle
réussit merveilleusement vous espériez
pas tant qu'entité je pensais pas qu'il
était comme un petit à petit par
ailleurs de gros du gros il avait pas la
moustache et longs métrages
il avait déjà des tendances mais pas les
mêmes que maintenant peut-être qui est
aussi maman tu t'es senti de l'alcool
faut pas mal non parce que si on a parlé
j'entends ça le choquer quand vous allez
chercher à l'école quand on était petits
c'était bourré devant les commissions
faire de sa part il faut plus en parler
parce que sa valeur ouais halvick si
c'est sûr et il se sert toujours sur
l'élastique c'est lui a pas passé bah
oui
m
à quel âge il a commencé à l'un
lui et demi oui un peu un peu retardé
c'est plutôt mais c'est vrai qu'il avait
le bouton rouge toujours oui c'est une
non il était en veille et déjà comme un
chien tu sais frère andy à bondir si ta
mère
on rappelle que roselyne est également
la maman de eric et ramzy qu'on embrasse
au passage on vous dit au revoir
[Applaudissements]
on va aller puis à toute heure et dans
la loge après l'émission
prenant pas les mamans
nous avons aussi je m'en fous mais
nettement moins ses cadres même que
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
en télévision année
ces bourses mondiales
bonne surprise belle surprise avec volé
ma mère ouais ouais je ne savais pas
qu'elle était gold ou bien alors vous
êtes ici pour la sortie d'un des films
les plus attendus de l'année qui
s'apaise
voilà donc c'est un film écrit par icc
ils ont fait exprès non fait pour ça
c'est fait pour ça morgan hacker servi à
acheter les billets ça sera bon jour
jouer une place pour donc un film qui
est écrit par les robins en
collaboration avec alain chabat joué par
les robins et alain chabat plus
depardieu rochefort valérie lemercier
dominique farrugia font des apparitions
pour le mérite aux légitimes parution
voilà et réalisé par alain chabat alors
le pitch je vais le faire je crois que
ce sera beaucoup plus simple
le pitch pas d'avoir le fond c'est le
premier thriller préhistorique
nous sommes en pleine préhistoire moins
trente cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ
et pour la première fois un crime est
commis
c'est la première fois qu'un homme tue
un autre homme alors pourquoi tu es qui
a tué
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit le premier
thriller préhistorique soit première
fois que va faire se pose est au niveau
de la forme c'est beaucoup moins
métaphysique mais c'est le premier
dessin animé dans les personnages sont
des vrais acteurs je crois qu'on peut le
dire
1 j'aime bien ouais c'est gentil mais si
c'est marina qu'a dit ça alors là donc
et la tribu des cheveux sales qui veut
voler le secret du shampoing à la tribu
des cheveux propres s elle le vaut bien
voilà
et alors tout le monde s'appelle pierre
parce qu'on est à l'âge de pierre épiler
les animaux videmment il ya des des
poules goutte chez les canards mousse et
puis il ya des vermouth qu'on a ici
derrière voilà ça c'est une espèce de
petite poule rousse brune tout le monde
sur une poule rousse laurent voilà c'est
ça c'est quoi ça leur coûte ça c'est un
énorme chantier un cochon montant soit
ça c'est le lapin mujila le lapin mouthe
et puis il ya le foot
lorsque tu vois là donc ça se passe
comme ça la moutte ya des mammouths mais
pas de mode voilà c'est portnawak en
fait c'est c'est ou non s'est basé sur
des faits réels et il ya eu beaucoup de
recherches sur le sur le sujet notamment
s'étant retrouvé sa grande époque
bon vous avez retrouvé des documents
blanc bien sûr un pécule à la couleur en
existerait à l'époque donc forcément les
enregistrements d'assez mauvaise qualité
mais qui nous a quand même permis de
travail et une base une base coiffe un
devoir à la véracité
voilà des bien sûr et beaucoup de drogue
vol quelques personnages du vous appelez
le blond non mais vous m'appelez pierre
j'aime pas qu'on appelle le blond lui
santé un petit peu différent des autres
ah oui c'est d'ailleurs c'est un film
sur la différence je crois qu'il faut le
dire tout de suite voilà je suis seule
blonde la tribu et je vis je vis assez
mal la différence pour ça que je suis un
personnage un peu renfermé
c'est un peu un personnage et la clau de
sauter dans le film quelque chose
quelque chose de sauter mais sans romy
schneider et michel piccoli mais bon un
drame rural comme c'est un personnage
assez assez épais au milieu de tout ça
un personnage un peu tourmenté voilà un
peu ton monte c'est la première fois que
je suis genre de personnage
je suis très content mais c'est vraiment
quelqu'un remarque mais oui c'est ça
promet
ces valeureux n'a jamais bah voilà si si
je l'espère marié fort j'ai vu mais j'ai
eu du mal à faire sur scène
donc c'est chabal et robin j'ai déjà dit
trois fois sortie nationale le 28
janvier 700 copies sûrement un cinéma
près de chez vous qu'il le joue parce
que 700 copies c'est énorme mais oui
c'est colossal
pas de vanne [ __ ] pas de vannes ouais
700 copies par rapport à l occasion
c'est beaucoup vous comptez faire quand
même entré à la à peu près avec mon film
précédent a fait 14 millions et demi
d'entrées devant espère doubler
ouais donc je pense qu'on va faire à la
voilà ce qu'on va faire
est ce qu'on va faire ce sera plus sûr à
faire plusieurs prises en juillet vous
comptez faire quand même entrer vous
allez me répondre d'abord 14,6 millions
quand on perd quand même très bas 14,6
millions là où maintenant vous me dire
si millions je vais faire combien
d'entrés vous les vrais chiffres
non je veux le chinois puis je prendrai
la meilleure prise en fonction des
entrées quand on est d'accord ça comme
ça vous aurez raison vous aurez toujours
présent dans huit - six millions à la
rage
vous allez faire quand même entré 6
millions 6 millions mais on va refaire
encore et si jamais on croit migraine
pour moi oui comme elle entraîne peu
dire 2 milliards alors noranda fait
quand même entrés et ont filmé deux
milliards
[Applaudissements]
2 milliards de milliards ce sont les
pertes de la production en anciens
francs en ancien pas là
[Applaudissements]
antoine vers 180 milles entre ses pairs
comme l entrée 180 me comme ma fille
alors est ce que vous êtes attaché de
presse sont là comme je crois que vivier
myriam myriam et n'a rien mais la très
bien là que myriam on va leur faire
plaisir on va faire les questions du
dossier de presse comme ça il n'y aura
pas de duras pas de problème mais on est
sûr que vous vous rendrez le fit alors
comment êtes vous arrivé sur ce projet
alain chabat c'est amusant que vous me
posiez cette question
comme comme comme producteur d'abord
dominique farrugia qui devait
initialement produire le film a été
appelé pour diriger canal+
bon ce poste allée lui prendre 120 % de
son temps il m'a donc contact avec les
robins des bois pour savoir si je
voulais produire c'est bien non mais ça
fait vraiment de cinéma je me connais
vraiment d'accord bien le terrain les
gens sont pas habitués à la spontanéité
rendez-vous à avoir du plaisir à jouer
même avec la pression de votre double
fonction alain chabat sûr si vous
réalisez que vous jouez sur février
mission de cinéma là c'est une bonne
question que personne n'a jamais posé ça
me fait plaisir
ardisson bon j'adore jouer j'adore
réaliser mais c'est vrai que les deux en
même temps n'était pas mon exercice
favori tout dire les jours où je faisais
acteur réalisateur
gt gt d'une humeur de d'ogm août
c'est très désagréable pour l'équipe
entre parenthèses qu'elle soit remerciée
pour sa patience mais ça m'a bien aidé
pour le rôle très bien
non at il pas été plus simple de tourner
le film en studio alors on ya pensé et
puis finalement jean rochefort accepté
ouais
alors quels souvenirs garderez-vous leur
voisine c'est toi j'ai entendu à laon
début de la question alain chabat à
quels souvenirs garderez-vous de haut il
y en a beaucoup tout ce joyeux liés au
bonheur de travailler avec des gens
décidés à donner le meilleur
quant aux robins il travaille autant
qu'ils déconnent fils ce sont de très
gros bosseur
merci alors jean paul et vous et vous et
vous et vous et vous attend vincent les
figurants juste après l'été durant le
témoignage de figurants en fin de mois
jean paul raconte c'est pas ça jean-paul
à la plage non plus jean-paul à une
érection ces paroles sont l'espagne
terrestres non jean pierre leblon
d'attributs machine et vous bien et vous
on s'en est excusé moi pardon excusez
moi
jean-paul pourquoi dans tout processus
de merger endemol
sans le regarder
non
nous attendons toujours
pendant des mois la dgre extrait de la
bo du film alors sur la bo yahia joey
starr ya ophélie winter et affable aussi
à busta flex il ya superbus
ouais on l'aimé bien jennifer d'or
génération c est bien dans le making of
en papier alors ça c'est extraordinaire
donc il ya le scénario semble pour ben
voilà ça c'est vraiment ton fils adorent
l'ordre si la bible et joui grave
il a aussi couvert les répliques il ya
le scénario original il y avait
storyboard je vous dessinez très bien
monsieur chabat merci tient vraiment et
puis à des photos aussi du tournage
enfin cet extrait i'm a man nul est
maintenant interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul interviews sont la bouche
attention ne dit rien vous êtes dans une
soirée claude berri vous vous salue en
vous appelant jean pierre rives
vous êtes obligé de sourire parce que
c'est claude berri vous souriez comme
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite
un photographe arrive au fait quelle
tête sur la photo jean-paul à ce moment
là une sublime gonzesses entre ne
regarde que vous vous êtes inaccessible
fait kate est inaccessible mais pas trop
il n'y a qu'ici mais pas trop ouais mais
pas trop inaccessible inaccessible h une
excessive mais au patro pas trop
à l'ats nicole kidman arrive dans cette
soirée où il ya claude berri déjà et
nicolas sarkozy mais c'est sa poésie est
alors êtes vous voient comme c'est fait
aïe
alan vous faites quoi vous mondial le
feront parce que c'est kidman excuses
voilà qui dit qu'est ce qui fait que ce
blaireau jean-paul vous vous croisez
quelqu'un de visiblement important en
fait vous l'avez pas reconnu ces deux
nouveaux comics et alain delon fait
quelle tête je me dis qu'un jour les
gens votent jean pierre guérin le
producteur de gilles escot vous raconte
vos débuts dans la série il vous propose
de revenir dans la série julie lescaut à
un million de francs l'épisode pizza
pizza pizza millions de francs l'épisode
alain vous embarquez nicole kidman on
est lui lui moi je rencontre jean pierre
guérin julie les statines alain milon
marque nicole kidman ses verrières en
même temps vous prenez votre voiture
vous allez prendre un dernier verre au
costes et là vous lui dites nicole
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je ne suis pas d'oran je suis
américain kader aoun je t'emmerde
ça c'est pour commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça que ma
jean-paul
vous quittez la soirée à deux tours j'en
avais marre d'être avec marion game
ghezzal et vous allez au cost ouais il
vous rencontrer alain chabat une colle
kidman qui sont en train de prendre un
dernier verre il fait l'américain à ce
cas vous vous essayez d'être là tous les
trois ou gacko et d'un seul coup
ophélie winter arrive chez bonjour au
filet mais comme chose dans les cheveux
je peux en parler
et là elle me demande pourquoi bah si
c'est un truc ardisson veut pas dire
bonjour normalement
chacun maintenant son talent lobby alain
chabat et dominique coach
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
hull avec nous ce soir
pour l'intégrer hull 2 alors les rues
[Applaudissements]
bien non pour l'inculper 1 vous aviez
choisi l'émission de marc olivier fogiel
par erreur et je sais pas il avait
commencé
il avait commencé son interview par une
question que je vais à nouveau vous vous
posez ce n'est pas qu'on commence par
leurs excuses par une question que je
vais à nouveau vous poser cette année
jean marie bigard va faire le stade de
france ça vous brancherait vous de faire
le stade de france on a répondu ajoutant
j'ai les réponses de l'époque choisie
oui bah tu as dit sisi bien sûr c'est si
bien sûr chantal a dit ah ouais ouais
l'époque j'étais petit mais la question
vous avez choisi si si à quand même même
si la nouvelle réponse a quand même pour
changer l emmène alors est ce que le
fait d'avoir fait l'integrilin r en
avoir vendu un million a joué dans le
fait de faire intégrer le 2 non ce qu'on
voulait c'était surtout faire un geste
auprès du public un geste de générosité
et leur donner du bonheur
d'accord mais c'est réussi alors
évidemment
ce qui fait drôle un peu maintenant
c'est pour voir des bonnes émissions de
canal on est obligé d'acheter des dvd
donc c'est sûr c'est un peu plus
compliqué qu'avant mais on peut y
arriver quoi je m'inscris en faux
vous avez la nostalgie des années canal
chantal non non non c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque si on prenait pas de drogue ont
été virés ce mois ci non non moi j'ai
tenu oui c'est vrai sinon voilà c'est
vrai qu'il y ait des [ __ ] à tous les
étages
en tout cas au nom d'al veine le dire à
la tenue pas mieux
pierre lescure se promener à poil dans
les couloirs c'est vrai ça c'est bien il
était très à la retombée 1
c'est la forme du nez comme le bavoir
c'est la réplique du village natal
heures et d'autres nouveaux dvd
s'appelle intègre hull 2 pourquoi pas eu
lui un chez buchet une lubie ou
dominique hurault du mais on y avait
pensé les finales mieux en sept duels et
push et non on avait fini la bouteille
de vin blanc
alors pour noël dans lequel il ya le
double dvd soit le double dvd soit le
coffret 4 dvd édition limitée collector
jusqu'à l'intérieur on a non seulement
l'intégrisme le livre des nuls plus tvn
595 plus toute l'histoire de la
télévision l'intégrale sur les quinze
jours nous vous offrons
est-ce que c'est intégrer le 2 peut
faire office de magnifiques cadeaux de
noël
mais plus que magnifique super
magnifique super 91 casi même le prix
offrir mais je préfère le 2 o 1 à huy
bizarrement j'aime les deux c'est pas
mal ça c'est parce que les gens ils sont
nés qui ont racheté leur enfin après une
terrible tenez vous à démentir la whey
vous avez mentir je sais pas faire moi
savoir combien ça va aller nul ne sait
plus à quoi tendent et non pas par la
santé le reste mais c'est comme fred
astaire et ginger rogers quoi c'est
quand vous êtes obligés de vous
retrouver c'est ouais mais on fait ça
pour l'argent
ouais ça vous plaît de faire la promo ça
n'est même pas du tout au rien dire
c'est pas moi ça me fait tout seul c'est
ça m'embête un peu parfois ça dépend
ouais il est bien ce dvd l'intégrale de
l'ain c'est une merde comment ta
question va être montée mais c'est une
[Rires]
il faut l'acheter pour noël ce qui me
rend banon tas d'autres trucs à acheter
hachette le dvd ma fille là à dire des
conneries comme ça on risque de vraiment
y compris la promo je vous le dis mais
c'est bien continuez
oui mais oui mais il peut dire aussi te
met à poil se mettra pas les seuils
voilà jamais je me met à poil moi mais
ça n'aurait pas coupé j'adore laurent
gerra c'est l'interview boîte vocale
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie des
monty python si vous avez piqué des
sketches veuillez laisser votre message
après le bip sonore c'est à vous claque
moi j'ai raccroché on leur a rien volé à
l'averse de certains certains autres
vers des monty python qui ne nous ont
volé des trucs qu'on avait l'intention
de faire un crève coeur
longtemps après bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie d'ophélie winter si vous êtes
prêts à faire la une de voici
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore c'est à vous salue ici d'homme ça
va bonjour vous êtes sur un message
michel drucker merci beaucoup de
m'appeler vraiment merci
veuillez laisser votre message après le
bip sonore temps on va tâcher n allait
pas la famille bonjour vous êtes sur la
messagerie de bruno karachi absent pour
le moment mais laissez votre message
après le bip sonore pourquoi ouais je
surtout qu'on sait c'est qu'à un moment
ou à un autre être revoir
ouais ouais ouais bonjour vous êtes sûrs
et messagerie de bertrand méheut
si vous avez l'esprit canal veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
c'est à vous salut c'est d'homme ça va
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
steven spielberg je sais ça calme
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore est gentil ça va on le fera pas
ce film donc ça va des traits sont a pas
les moyens donc laisse tomber tu feras
pas l'intégrer de 3,9 à bonjour vous
êtes sur les messageries de jean marie
messier si c'est pas pour de l'argent
veuillez laisser votre message après le
bip sonore alors quoi de neuf gens
mariés toujours la beauté de 18 mois
qu'est ce que tu veux bonjour vous êtes
sur la messagerie de nicole kidman si
vous êtes dominique farrugia veuillez
laisser un message après le bip sonore
nicole je suis pris les ce mois ci subit
ça suffit je rappellerai que même après
bonjour vous êtes son ami serge bilé
ppda je suis chez mon coiffeur vous
alors veuillez laisser votre message
ça devrait être rapide tu peux me
rappeler que j'ai vécu l'émission de
stéphane bern gardien de l'esprit canal
veuillez laisser un message après le bip
sonore garde le bien bonjour vaisseau la
messagerie des nuls nous sommes en
tournée le vin chez ardisson le 25 chez
denisot le 26 chez cauet de 27 ch
échanges 28 chez pascal classe le 22 à
asnières complémentaires 34 veuillez
laisser votre message après le bip
sonore s'il vous plaît nous serons aussi
en signature à la fnaa que le 31 et le
prend 2 et quelqu'un une vanne oui le
tram 2 c'est pas possible
à bâle
voilà
alors alain chabat alain vous avez un
autre dvd vaut un autre dvd c'est didier
là aussi c'est une édition collector
limitée
ok ce qu'il ya dedans alors il ya vu un
making of et du storyboard voilà et des
petits trucs
il ya quelques making of quoi est-ce que
pourriez faire le pitch de didier ouais
c'est un c est jean pierre bacri qui est
manager de l'équipe de foot qui un jour
on lui confie un chien et un jour ce
chien se transforme en sommes voilà
pourquoi j'ai envie de dire parce que va
le foot m'intéresse c'est une [ __ ] c'est
une fable je crois c'est une fable sur
la tolérance sur l'amour sur cette fable
est très ancré dans la réalité sur
évidemment il suffit d'avoir un rayon
bleu qui transforme en chien à ce moment
là tout devient possible
un rayon bleu et danse à l'explication
du vin blanc alors en plus donc il ya le
making of il ya l'interview du dresseur
et puis à vos retrouvailles avec avec le
chien avec elliott le chien huit ans
après ouais ça s'est passé comment il
avait un peu vieilli pas moi et mais bon
c'est des années chien quand même une
année chien c'est sept ans qu'il a
compris pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne sent
pas le cul non tu repas il ne veut pas
retravailler avec jean-pierre alors
appât didier 2 way rally veut pas non
plus pas construire
[Musique]
j'accueille à chabat et maurice
barthélémy
bonsoir j'ai basé ma part dont marche
encore à ces trucs là à toute démarche
et moi je fais il révélé je crois qu'ils
l'ont alors bonsoir bonsoir on se voit
bonsoir à laurent soir commence très
fort bonsoir on ne présente plus maurice
barthélémy chez lequel certains maurice
barthélémy on ne présente plus
damman mais alors
en bolivie d'un père diplomate devenu
menuisier en picardie maurice barthélémy
ouais c'est bien fumé un groupe est
avant de faire la bio membre des robins
des bois réalisateur de casablanca
driver l'histoire du plus mauvais boxeur
de tous les temps maurice barthélémy
papa de tess la fille de judith godrèche
voilà en revanche on connaît moins alain
chabat ça va pas trop intimidé un peu
quand même
il est moins connu la moins l'habitude
de faire de la télé le petit alain
chabat peut-être que les lecteurs de
voici le connaissent un peu quand même
vous est donné du mal pour être dans la
voici
mais ça y est alors alain chabat a fait
a fait des films l'histoire d'un chien
qui devient un homme un l'histoire d'un
arabe qui boit de la potion magique
aussi tout à fait un jeune maghrébin
l'histoire d'hommes préhistoriques qui
commettent un crime enfin vous avez déjà
fait quelques quelques trucs à la cbi
également réalisé une cassette de
bricolage avec des figurines de prix
gold cup
et a fait partie d'un groupe j'ai fait
partie d'un groupe go de musique non non
non de comics va pallier tous de quoi tu
voudrais pardon au temps pour moi
voilà vous êtes ici tous les deux pour
un film de maurice interprété par alain
chabat que c'est le papa qui sort le 1er
juin
et là je tiens à dire ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas vu un film
aussi bien parce que tu en as vu des
maires de certaines émissions obligé d'y
aller un nom celui-là c'est un film
extraordinaire je suis sorti de là
j'étais complètement bouleversé
carrément en larmes quoi ça m'a vraiment
je crois que depuis le goût des autres
j'ai pas pleurer comme ça les embiez au
6 août a été très très bon bien sûr
alors je vais pas raconter le pitch
parce que je veux pas dévoiler
l'histoire ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
c'est un road movie
il ya un break volvo avec un père et son
fils le fils à à 8 ans il roule alors on
sait pas très bien on sait pas très bien
où ils sont d'abord on ne sait pas très
bien d'où ils viennent
où ils vont tout ça on le saura à la fin
mais on comprend quand même que quelque
chose de grave a eu lieu et pendant tout
le film on s'interroge on est très en
fait très attentif à tout et on ne sait
pas très bien on comprend petit à petit
quoi exactement c'est à dire qu'en fait
j'ai essayé de placer des indices dans
le film de manière à ce que bon bah le
spectateur au fur et à mesure élabore sa
propre hypothèse et se disent qu'est ce
qui s'est passé entre deux et puis voilà
à un moment on raconte ce qui se passe
mais là on sait filmer au plus près en
plus c'est comme ça c'est très
authentique c'est très pudique c'est
très délicat
il n'y a pas deux il ya pas de pathos et
on sent effectivement qu'il ya une
lourdeur qui rôdent consent qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose et et on sait pas
quoi un truc grave bas un deuil ça on
peut le dire il ya un deuil ya eu un
décès
en fait il ya le père qui suit à ce
deuil à un temps tendance un petit peu à
saint fanti lisez et l'enfant lui du
coup à mûrir un peu plus vite et les
deux comme ça vont se chercher un petit
peu pendant le film et puis au bout d'un
moment il va y avoir une bascule et puis
il ya un personnage qui arrivent et qui
vient remettre les deux à leur place
alors là vous êtes d'un naturel
époustouflant dans ce film par rapport
aux autres filles vous l'avez toujours
bon les jambons non mais c'est vrai
c'est extraordinaire
ces cas bravo vraiment ça dure une heure
20h18 exactement on est dans la caisse
avec les deux on s'ennuie jamais c'est
un sacré pari en même temps oui mais moi
il ya un truc dont je suis
particulièrement fier c'est que les gens
quand ils ressortent du du film et ils
me disent [ __ ] on n'a jamais vu chabat
comme ça et c'est vrai que m c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai il est il est
incroyable dans le film et le petit
garçon martin et et bouleversant il a il
a une mélancolie sur le visage il a une
nostalgie naturel ce gosse c'est
extraordinaire ils n'étaient pas payés
par rapport à là c'est vrai
ça a aidé en tout cas assez rare les
films qui font le pari de l'intelligence
à notre époque et ça c'en est un
voilà je n'ai rien d'un organe on a
envie de il ya un moment il ya un plan
dans un rétroviseur où il ya un qui a
des lunettes noires il ya une larme qui
coule comme ça sous les lunettes noires
c'est magique c'est magnifique à maurice
vraiment séduit qu'il faut féliciter
pour le coup il écrivait ça pendant le
pendant le tournage de re c'est ça ouais
il a réussi à écrire en même temps
casablanca driver re et papa oui on
viendra un camouflet dedans j'ai rien
dit il a eu des velléités de réalisation
non non pas du tout avant il a fait
l'acteur la totale et ils les conseils
qui me donnait c'était plutôt des
conseils de papa finale mais de la paix
de moelle et patrick baz et moi à
l'époque j'étais papa 1 et dont lui me
disait tiens ça c'est peut-être à
peut-être un peu trop là dessus il a
peut-être un peu idéalisée le papa est
là peut-être le falloir le rendre un peu
plus rugueux voilà il ya beaucoup
d'impro aussi parce que la scène de
l'alsacienne ensemble c'est de l'impro
c'est à dire la fille arrive parfois
vous êtes habillé en alsaciennes c'est
la semaine de l'alsace après voilà puis
vous vous dites au moment même les
garçons sont habillés et puis martin
c'est un petit gars qui éternue c'est
très rare les acteurs qui éternue en
pleine prise il éternue
mais je garde à chaque fois je garde les
éternuements pour sa trop mignon et
j'étais du pollen qui avec des ventes il
est mort ce gosse alors vous disiez
c'est un 5 min depardieu cirque il est
capable de rentrer dans le film tout de
suite quoi ils se concentrent
instantanément ouais mais c'est un vrai
branleur entre les prises ils n'arrêtent
pas de faire chier tout le monde
alain au bout d'un moment on lui disait
je vais te casser le nez ou
il lui a mis un beau pays on peut le
dire oui mais bon des gens gentiment
comme comme un enfant tu vois un n'est
pas mort d'homme non ça va il va bientôt
jouer démis l'épaule
vous êtes papa maintenant alors oui
depuis un mois tu veux le garder
pascal pape aly cissokho ce qu'on
vérifie si vous êtes des bon papa et
qu'on fasse une interview papa est-ce
que vous avez déjà regretter d'avoir eu
un enfant
pardon j'ai regretté d'avoir eu un
enfant
non j'ai déjà demandé un test de
paternité parce que l'enfant avait l'air
un peu con demander un test de paternité
parce que l'enfant avait l'air un peu
vif vous avez déjà fait un enfant pour
faire plaisir à la mer non non ah non
maintenant bien vous rappelez de toutes
les mères de vos enfants oui au la
plupart
vous avez assisté à la naissance
dernièrement vaut bien sûr vous avez
filmé ah non ah ouais j'ai assisté
j'étais derrière elle moi je voulais
être devant elle elle m'a dit non tu dis
que c'est mieux vous avez déjà changer
les couches de vos enfants mais oui les
biberons vous les faites à elle allaite
mettais pas très très bien au début
ouais un peu le bordel que les couches
l'allaitement est ce que vous avez déjà
giflé un enfant régulièrement ben martin
le petit martin
par exemple j'ai déjà oublié votre
enfant quelque part à part sur le toit
de ma voiture non vous proposez de la
drogue à vos enfants pour être sûr
qu'ils en prennent
je demande un temps mort dans cette
interview je ne peux plus aller
mais là s'arrête mais est-ce que vous
avez déjà demandé à votre enfant de rien
dire à la mer à propos de l'actrice
dénudées qui étaient là pour sa carrière
en fait vous arriver ça répéter je vous
ai déjà demandé à votre enfant de rien
dire à sa mère à propos de ces deux
jeunes actrices dénudées qui voulait
juste des oui non oui tout à fait non
c'était un mais en plus ils auraient pu
en parler septembre c'est vraiment
passionnant
en fait l'affairé oui vu qu'on leur
fasse est troisième mais je serai
toujours pas d'avoir d'abord étonné de
revenir
je n'aurai pas de vanne mais je sais
même pas qui va être drôle vas-y est-ce
que vous avez déjà demandé votre enfant
à propos de ces deux jeunes actrices
dénudées qui voulait juste des conseils
pour sa carrière
nous à utiliser votre enfant pour
draguer des filles dans les jardins
publics
non je peux pas la main mois et toujours
avec la petite c'est impossible
vous êtes déjà fait travailler votre
enfant à la non encore bien moins ça
peut te faire un tapis de 2 mètres
carlingue
ce jour là j'ai perdu un pognon pour les
ordinateurs et des pompes mais j'ai
regardé les télétubbies sans prendre de
drogue à la wii et je me suis fait chier
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait oh qu'il
est mignon ouagadougou 12 au bout du
goût doux oui mais en regardant sa [ __ ]
il se tourne ça vous est déjà premier à
sa mère que jamais au grand jamais où la
quitterai away
non mais ça c'est sûr c'est sûr elle est
la femme de ma vie ah oui un texto un
texto de judith pour dire que ces bars
et salles tombée est-ce que votre enfant
vous a déjà appelé monsieur tellement
n'était pas habitué à vous voir la
maison
je salue l'équipe de khl et ils n'ont
toujours pas déjà caresser les cheveux
d'autres enfants en pensant à l'économie
d'impôt que ça vous fait faire déjà j'en
viens pas qu'elle ait des cheveux ouais
nan franchement je ne signerai pas pris
cette son père c'est vrai qu'elle n'a
plus de cheveux que vos gardes mais
paraît que si le film marche et vous
laisser pousser les cheveux c'est vrai
je vais me payer une perruque en or à
aller très bien
vous avez collet bébé à bord à l'arrière
de votre porsche cayenne alors j'ai
juste le bébé à bord ils vous avez
jamais regretté de pas avoir pris un
chien plutôt n'ont aucune news
non non juste si je trouve de la vanne
contrat de the border un moment et vous
l'intégrer
jusqu'à samedi s'est diffusée samedi
j'irai réponse vannes demain vendredi
mais j'ai la réponse tu viens on
rappelle les gens et s'en foutent
j'aurai un pool et on tourne laval est
ce que vous avez peur que vos enfants
vous ressemble un jour mon nom mais
apparemment les gens disent qu'elle me
ressemble je vais vite sans les jolies
[Musique]
ça sort
aïe aïe aïe
chaque joueur doit vous donner 1000
euros de trésors vous devez trouver
catherine barma et l'embrassé sur la
bouche sur la bouche
[Musique]
alors comment c'était des lèvres d'une
douceur avec catherine une grande
amoureuse un bonsoir bonsoir charlotte
bon soir là t'as vu quelqu'un que tu
connaissais tu vois comme ça tout le
monde s'amuse à le saluer là là quand on
vous connaissez le rituel de cette
dernière émission
les invités sont chargés de nous poser
une question déjà éventé sont chargés à
moi
je commençais à la je sais pas si on
vous l'a déjà posé série comment vous
savez tout ça c'est tout con c'est parce
que je travaille
voilà mais comment vous savez tout ça
parce que les gens qui travaillent pour
moi sont très bons aussi
oui d'accord
alors
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux bien savoir ce que tu penses
toi
écoute je pense que j'ai pas encore fait
tout ce que j'avais à faire et que vous
n'avez pas fini d'entendre parler de
thierry ardisson
[Applaudissements]
à
il est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
alors une question pour laurent baffie
ya là j'ai une question d'intérêt
général et une question de zoologie
qu'est ce que vous préférez laurent
zoologie écologie parce que vous avez
une théorie sur le fait que le homard
est un vieillissant non j'ai pas de
théorie là-dessus mais je crois qu'on a
beaucoup à découvrir du homard il y
avait des traces et écrites quand on
écrit par omar m'a tuer ça pose une
vraie question et je crois qu'on est au
début des connaissances sur le
faible alors ouais d'accord
donc qu'est-ce qu'on va faire le samedi
soir qu'est ce que vous vous allez faire
le sale et sur les gens ils vont
reprendre une vie normale ils vont se
désaccoutumer ils vont refaire l'amour à
leurs familles vont voilà quoi ali vont
ils vont regarder d'autres chaînes ou
pas est peut-être le meilleur conseil à
donner aux gens ce serait d'éteindre la
télé de faire autre chose que de
regarder la télé puisque maintenant il y
aura plus rien de bien les gens
regarderont vont mettre un super
programme qui va cartonner voilà les
gens regarderont l'émission de laurent
ruquier qui sera à cet endroit la halle
samedi soir alors sérieusement vous êtes
ici tous les deux ce soir pour le
nouveau film de michel gondry s'appelle
la science des rêves avec vous il ya
gael garcia bernal miu miu emma de
caunes
ça sort le 16 août michel gondry c'est
un réalisateur qui a commencé en faisant
des clips pour bjork pour daft punk et
isabelle giordano juge les clips de
michel gondry assez farfelue j'ai trouvé
ça charmant vous ce n'est pas atteint je
me souviens pas assez faire farfelue
mais c'est un garçon assez farfelu week
assez farfelue selon douala alors c'est
un mec a fait donc des clips ensuite il
a fait human nature et eternal sunshine
fin voilà il avait toujours d'un autre
trouve qu'il a un univers très déjanté
voilà alors le pitch je fais le pitch
avec plaisir bah oui c'est un des
derniers pics que je ferais pas
giordanno qui va le faire alors le pitch
c'est l'histoire de stéphane interprété
par gael garcia bernal qui est timide
qui est inhibée dont la vie prend enfin
un sens quand il se laisse convaincre
par sa mère de retourner en france pays
de son enfant soit là mais il est très
déçu par le boulot soit des enfants
formidables qui l'attend il bosse dans
une entreprise de calendrier et il
compense par ses rêves voilà et devant
des caméras en carton
sa revente une émission de télévision
sur le sur le rêve un peu comme nos
bientôt un ballon c'est un film
prémonitoire
alors alain vous le héros vous
rencontrent dans l'entreprise de
calendrier vous devenez vous donner à
ses amis tous les deux et vous charlotte
vous êtes la voisine dont le héros
tombent amoureux mais il finit par vous
faire peur pas mal de stéphane roulera
encore m vous êtes des gosses quoi c'est
un film qui qui fait qu'on se sent bien
en sortant quand même à charlotte vous
avez trouvé la meilleure définition du
film pour moi vous dites gondry raconte
des trucs qui sont a priori pas grave
mais de manière très graves comme des
enfants ouais c'est vrai que ça me fait
une réponse plus court sur le montage et
vont se faire chier grave mais sous les
voiliers en fait
bon on peut se tutoyer si tu veux si tu
veux parler du film qui parle du film
sinon c'est pas grave c'est vrai que
vous dressez question très original donc
le film devient le film est très
original alors le bruit novembre il ya
un autre film vous êtes ensemble une
comédie romantique qui s'appelle prête
moi ta main d'eric lartigau gtc faire le
le pitch c'est l'histoire d'un gamin de
luis que je
je joue qui est entouré de sa maman et
de ses cinq soeurs qui est donc très
très étoffé merci aux népalais est tout
à fait et il lui met une pression elle
lui met une pression terrible pour
qu'ils se marient et décide de en fait
de lui faire rencontrer une fille voilà
j'ai fait venir toute épreuve
ouais mais décide de louer une fille une
femme
enfin bart et âme pour pas qu'ils les
pauses
disons pour la présenter le plus tôt à
ses parents voilà à sa famille alors en
vue d'un mariage
oui c'est qu'en fait mais voilà on se
dit lui n'en veut pas dire la fin
oui mais quand même gestuelle pour
allécher voilà il se dit je vais la
présenter à ma famille ça va se passer
très bien elles vont elles vont l'adorer
on va annoncer notre mariage est en fait
elle viendra pas au mariage et je vais
tomber dans une profonde dépression et
plus personne ne me ferait chier ces
histoires de wallace et son plan qui va
pas être du tout se passait quand même
bien sûr c'est gerry le film c'est
vraiment très drôle ça s'appelle prête
moi ta main ça sort le 1er novembre
moi je les lui aussi très bien mais
c'est bien et comme vous serez vous
n'êtes pas là à la rentrée si je peux
continuer sur ma promo de l'année parce
que j'aurais pu démission nous sortons
un dvd des nuls
ah c'est dommage c'était pratique aussi
pour ça cette émission objectif nul en
dvd voilà et puis vous avez autres j'ai
une panda à vendre expliqué franchement
qui est encore en très bon état
vous êtes tout le temps ensemble à tous
les deux maintenant là le film de gondry
le film de lartigau je passe de t'être
quelque chose ils vont au bout d'un
moment non 1 est bien aussi une chose
que je veux dire c'est que le 30 juin
donc est la fête des loges
le bracelet wpt est assez gentil c'est
normal alain s'occupe d'une association
qui s'appelle les toiles enchantées très
discret là dessus l'idée c'est d'emmener
des films qui sont à la fiche dans les
hôpitaux où les enfants sont
hospitalisés à long terme et de passer
les films récents comme voilà tous les
films récents familiaux et donc aux à la
fête des loges les forains donne pendant
une journée la recette à l'association
il faut acheter un petit bracelet tout
15 euros et qui donne droit à toutes les
attractions voilà tous les manèges
c'est bien
j'ai vu des reportages sur cette
association dont vous occuper les toiles
enchantées
quand les enfants sont à l'hosto malade
et qu'on leur apporte les films qui sont
sortis une semaine avant salle c'est
fabuleux
même la semaine de la semaine a sorti
c'est vrai il voit le voilà au cinéma
c'est vrai quand le quand les enfants
peuvent pas se déplacer c'est au cinéma
de se déplacer donc voilà c'est super
[Applaudissements]
chabat fait discret donc alain est
tellement discret qu'on va faire une p
review la vérité sur alain chabat
alain chabat est ce que oui ou non vous
avez pécho paris s'il tonne la semaine
dernière à los angeles
non j'étais à tourcoing est ce que oui
ou non on finit winter vous a mis dans
son cv à la rubrique expérience
professionnelle non mais c'est une très
bonne vanne est ce que oui ou non vous
avez perdu 10 kilos non
[Rires]
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes toujours
faim qui fraîche à la wii je suis funky
frêche ce sujet l'apparence comme ça
d'un garçon un petit peu un petit peu
gros un petit peu mais à l'intérieur je
suis un grand noir extrêmement musclé
que c'est très bien
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes heureux
- depuis que vous arrêter mais sinon oui
je sais aujourd'hui est ce que oui ou
non j'ai devenu producteur de films à
hollywood
je suis j'essaye d'apporter la merguez à
hollywood en ce moment je travaille là
dessus je sais qui est intéressant est
ce que vous n'en depuis cinq ans on
pouvait choquer toutes les actrices
françaises que vous voulez à la
oui bien sûr est ce que oui ou non
dominique farrugia vous surnomme le
serpent à lunettes
oui mais
il m'énerve c'était mon sur dans le
serpent lunettes est ce que oui ou non
les nuls vont se reformer un jour
peut-être
en tout cas nous sortons un dvd
effectifs à la rentrée
est ce que oui ou non chantal lauby a
baisé avec un des nuls non et c'est pas
on a franchement on a essayé voulait
rien savoir
est ce que oui ou non canal est avant
tout une aventure humaine merveilleuse
dans laquelle vous avez vécu les plus
belles années de votre vie et qui nous a
permis d'accomplir vos rêves les plus
fous
merci oui canal est avant tout une
aventure merveilleuse way dans laquelle
j'ai pu accomplir mes rêves les plus
fous je me souviens plus bien du milieu
maintenant
rappelons que l'anagramme de alain
chabat donne habitat canal
ah ouais ouais j'ai trouvé ça en
cherchant en rangeant des casse tête je
vais ça fait classe maine nord est ce
que oui ou non vous avez retrouvé
l'esprit canal avec stéphane bern amor
amor est ce que oui ou non vous la péter
un peu depuis astérix
je me la suis toujours péter c'était pas
terrible mais après je l'appelle plus en
plus est ce que oui ou non vous étiez un
danger pour le gouvernement
et c'est pour ça qu'on a essayé de
descendre le field et robin ne rien dire
non est ce que oui ou non on préfère le
chien là maintenant
maintenant que je sais qu'elles sont
toutes différentes cartes et les vous
devez envoyer un texto à steven
spielberg rust event scale berges
spielberg spielberg heures spielberg a
non mais j'ai pas mon portable
sinon je l'aurais fait bien sûr
évidemment son numéro prend une autre
non c'est tout les mains c'est que la
peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]